i love going to round one offline yeah
yeah wait a second oh my god the manager
recognized me once she like she started
crying i was like
yeah we were around one the other day
and one of the employees there was like
oh you can just just come come up and
i'll just get you a ticket yeah yeah i
was just like oh okay cool i felt really
bad because there was like a bunch of
people lining up i'm like no no i'll
wait in the world you got a free ticket
yeah [ __ ] i paid for mine
i wish i wish he
fixed that stupid mega stacker machine
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] oh it's a machine
where the blocks you know they go across
and you gotta yeah they skip it they
they give it i i yeah absolutely skip it
yeah i've played that one yeah yeah you
know the one because
i'm a gamer so like no i can get to the
last one no problem i'm not a [ __ ]
idiot and then it you press it and it
[ __ ] goes
right over there intentionally yeah
it has to be on like a lottery system
i went on a date with a guy once and we
went around one it was so heckin fun
because he's like more of a normie and
i'm just like gaming my ass off
and he has a little like card with the
money and he's like and i'm like and
he's like
again okay
and i was stuck on that one for so long
and i knew
no i knew i was doing it right it's a
con dude i was getting so pressed and
he's like again okay
yeah
yeah
this game is by nice to wear to god i am
doing a frame perfect input no
the summoning salt video was in the
making dude yeah
it was
it was yeah i i think we i spent like an
hour on ski ball trying to get uh
eight you know the 10 000 in the corner
like the hardest one to get i was like
i'm gonna get eight out of nine to get
the bonus and i could only get seven i
was like a machine though you were there
for like an hour and a half just trying
to do something
i had dudes come up to me who were like
dude you're [ __ ] sick at this [ __ ]
and like
they spun me and i'm like i'm i do not
care i want these tickets leave me the
[ __ ] alone it was it was like it was
like seeing connor
yeah right it was like seeing kind of
playing irl jump king because it was
just like the same movement over and
over before i swear
the body
because i remember at one point in the
night i was like i saw you from across
the room like playing ski ball and i'm
like okay he's playing ski ball just go
to the rhythm machine games a couple of
times yeah i feel i was there for like
an hour i came back and he's like still
there but like 10 times sweatier yeah
yeah i was really getting into it
because i was getting i my goal was to
get as many high scores as the thing as
possible i'd got like the high score
like my second try on this bean bag
tossing [ __ ] and i was like dude i'm
actually nuts i just got to get the high
score on everything yeah and yeah that
broke me there was also another thing
that like there was just like this
[ __ ] milk tossing thing and it was
driving me insane and i was getting
angry that i couldn't get the high
school yeah it was like a milk jug i
need to throw a ball into it but it was
the the thing was designed so the ball
wouldn't bounce in nicely yeah and it
was i was like is it me
my bad am i not getting a jug [ __ ]
yeah i was like freaking out at this
round one you know i can get over a jug
being [ __ ] or me not perfecting my
skee ball but yeah that when it when
they actually progress yeah yeah what is
progressing to make you lose oh that was
that's yeah then it's a scam right
yeah yeah that's why i get addicted to
games where i know it's not a scam and
i'm just bad because i'm like i like i
know i'm the i'm the problem but when
they con me i'm like vehemently against
it i'm like absolutely [ __ ] not i
hate you i hate you so much
see that's why i was like glad i was a
casual gamer because we all started with
the same amount of credits i think me
and joey just spent like an hour or two
in the rhythm game section just having a
[ __ ] great time and then we come over
to connor and he's like almost ran out
of credit yeah and we're like dude we
got like 500 credits left there's all's
just like
that's why i like rhythm games though
because you
you you get the experience you pay it's
value for money
you get value for money
right skeeball was only like 25 cents
apart yeah but you you ran through that
in like 10 seconds your happiness at the
end they're your happiness yeah yeah
yeah i walked away with a minecraft glow
up light i'm probably not yeah
i'm sorry i spent my money faster than
anything yeah yeah i i we literally
spent like half the amount that you
spent because like i i'd like i remember
like oh we're all rich it's fine it's a
competition for
no because like i remember we were just
playing like the rhythm games i'm like
damn you get three songs for one credit
yeah holy [ __ ] it's like a good 10
minutes at least he's one credit and
here's connor going
like it's only three credits guys it's
like i didn't know you could speed run
skeeball
the one thing i will say that i think
round one america does better than round
one japan or anything
is the card
oh yeah none of the arcades in japan
even though they have cards that keep
your progression no one has decided on a
system that allows you to just load up
money on the card because like it's so
simple yeah there is a system it's just
not used as often yeah and i it only
works for some machines and so there's
you can play with like circa which is
like a tapping thing but the thing is
[ __ ] like to pick the thing you want
to play with pick the money you have to
pay with then have to hold it and it
doesn't work as well yeah yeah i do
these videos where i do like the crane
game uh playing against each other and i
have to carry around just a sack of
money to just put in it it's fine
that's kind of funny for the video yeah
yeah but it's i've spilled it before and
it's really awkward so i'm like
but also great for the video yeah it's
gonna how do i hold all this money
it is a visceral feeling going like
doom doom yeah yeah it's nice but when
you're spamming a game yeah yeah
yeah they have irl gotcha as well like
they have like uh you put like a ten
bucks in and then you get like a ball
and then you might you can win like that
oh yeah that was fun as [ __ ] yeah i do
like doing those but uh i've never won
anything good only uh pokemon arceus but
i already had a copy of it so
it's just sitting in my room
it was kind of high yeah it's kind of
nice no it was a waste of money ron one
is so fun
it's good it is yeah i want america's
really good i thought it was dog [ __ ] i
was kind of surprised too when i went to
the one year here because because i've
been to some pretty [ __ ] sad arcades
in the u.s yeah yeah i went to a dave
and buster's
you think arcades are bad like they can
be bad here in the uk they are pathetic
oh my god there is nothing in the union
well in australia as well this year yeah
when i went to round one like i i had
such a great time i thought about all
the people that only know of david
you know is dave and buster's band yeah
because
prior to this time most
mid arcade you could possibly think of
same thing you say submit arcade
compared to the arcades in the uk that's
still like a 10 out of 10 arcades if the
machines work it's better than the one
in the uk yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah half
of them they never work the buttons are
like i remember they had like uh this is
one really popular arcade in london just
half the machine just don't work
yeah time crisis you can you can put the
money in but the gun just doesn't
[ __ ] track yeah but you've already
put your money in so yeah
and like if it's if you get a machine
that's like
it's impossible to get a machine that's
like below functional yeah fully
functional below like 10 years old
because all the games like old as hell
like here you actually get like proper
rhythm games proper arcade games proper
claw machines and you get this [ __ ]
nothing yeah i was surprised how
up-to-date the round one was where we
went to especially like the rhythm games
i was like oh this is nothing like yeah
from japan this is nothing like the dave
and busters that i went to that one time
yeah
dude there's this like
mech game that you can play in japanese
arcades that's so [ __ ] sick we get to
pilot a mech and it's got hydraulics and
it [ __ ] moves around it's so funny
and it's a battle royale as well yeah so
so you're literally battling against the
mech pilots yeah other mech pilots
online and you are literally piloting a
map there's that many
mechs oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah even
in the 1rk the one we went to where we
discovered that game there was like i
think eight machines yeah yeah
fully like hydraulic machines that you
see you have to put where seat belt yeah
because oh my god or it won't stop so
like when you move forward it's like
when you actually like lean back yeah
yeah it's it's awesome and it's like a
hundred yen yep i don't have like the
best hacking time step out yeah